foreign
[Music]
Spencer here for Jihad watch a program
of the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
for the center for security policy
the Jihad against the freedom of speech
is advancing rapidly and most people
don't even know it's happening
turkeys on a dolu agency reported
recently that Google's first page
results for searches of terms such as
Jihad Sharia and takiya now return
mostly reputable explanations of the
Islamic Concepts takiyah which describes
the circumstances under which a Muslim
can conceal their belief in the face of
persecution is the sole term to feature
a questionable website on the first page
of results
reputable according to whom questionable
according to whom Google is bowing to
pressure from Muslims such as the Texas
Imam Omar Suleiman who led the
initiative to compel Google to skew its
results without considering whether
those who are demanding that the search
results be manipulated in a particular
direction might have an ulterior motive
could it be that those who are
pressuring Google want to conceal
certain truths about Islam that they
would prefer non-muslims not to know
this is a real possibility there's a
large scale Islamic initiative to compel
the West to accept Sharia blasphemy laws
under the guise of stamping out hate
speech an initiative that is now
Galloping forward and achieving immense
success
but of course Google Executives would
have to study Islam themselves in order
to determine whether or not these
Muslims who are pressuring them are
misleading them and that's not going to
happen
still they could have done a bit more
due diligence and made some effort to
determine whether those being tarred as
hate groups really deserve the label
whether the Southern Poverty Law Center
was really a reliable and objective
Arbiter of which groups were and were
not hate groups and whether the
information that Google was suppressing
was really inaccurate instead Google
seems to have swallowed uncritically
everything Omar Sulaiman and the others
told them
Omar Suleiman himself however is still
not satisfied
one leading activist in favor of Google
modifying its results said the anado
agency told the agency that he noticed
the updated search results and thanked
the company for its efforts but said
much still needs to be done
Suleiman claimed that Google has a
responsibility he said to combat
hate-filled islamophobia similar to how
they work to suppress extremist
propaganda from groups like daesh and Al
Qaeda
daesh is of course the Islamic State
this should have made Google Executives
stop and think the Islamic State in Al
Qaeda slaughter people gleefully and
call openly for more mass murders there
is no firm evidence on the other hand
that anyone has ever been killed by a
so-called hate-filled islamophobe and
the claim that Hamas linked care and the
Southern Poverty Law Center make in the
in the anadolo agency article that this
supposed islamophobic rhetoric has led
to a rise in hate crimes against Muslims
is supported by not a scintilla of
evidence
Omar Suleiman is equating critical words
with murderous deeds and Google should
have realized at that point that he had
an agenda and was not being honest
Sulaiman himself however tried to pose
as an impartial Arbiter the agency's
article continues Suleiman said Google
should differentiate between criticism
of Islam and hate-filled islamophobia
emphasizing the religion should not be
infringed upon
now that's not clear Omar Suleiman
apparently is saying that there is
acceptable criticism of Islam that is
not hate-filled islamophobia but if that
is so then the religion can be infringed
upon at least by this legitimate
criticism no or if the claim that Islam
must not be infringed upon means that it
cannot be criticized
why is that so of Islam but not of any
other religion
Suleiman says I don't think Google has a
responsibility to portray Muslims
positively I think he said Google has a
responsibility to weed out
fear-mongering and hate groups but I
don't want Google to silence critique of
Islam or critique of Muslims
the problem with this is that neither
Omar Suleiman nor care nor the splc nor
anyone else who has ever said that there
was a distinction between legitimate
criticism of Islam and hate-filled
islamophobia has ever identified anyone
he thinks is a legitimate critic of
Islam who is not islamophobic
over 16 books now as well as thousands
of Articles and over forty five thousand
blog posts I myself have attempted to
present a reasonable documented fair and
accurate criticism of Islam an
explanation of jihad Doctrine
nevertheless I've been tarred as a
purveyor of hate-filled islamophobia by
groups and individuals that have never
given my work a fair hearing but have
read it only in search of gotcha quotes
that they could wrench out of their
obvious benign meaning in order to claim
that I was saying something hateful
and this of course doesn't happen only
to me it happens to anyone and everyone
who dares to utter a critical word about
Islam or Jihad wherever they are on the
political Spectrum
this experience reinforced countless
times over a decade and a half makes me
extremely skeptical when Omar Sulaiman
says that he doesn't want Google to
silence criticism of Islam if he could
produce some critique of Islam that he
actually approved of my skepticism might
lessen but he won't and he can't
it seems much more likely that he
pressured Google to skew its results so
as to deep six criticism of Islam but
knowing that he couldn't tell them that
he was trying to bring Google into line
with Sharia blasphemy laws forbidding
criticism of Islam he told them instead
that he wasn't against criticism of
Islam as such but only against
hate-filled islamophobia
Mr Suleiman if you and your colleagues
hadn't spent years tarring all rational
criticism of Islam that was accurate and
presented in good faith as hate-filled
islamophobia I might have believed you
but is one of your primary victims I do
not I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]